finalizan 90 días de campaña electoral
en Guatemala marcados por la polémica de
un presunto fraude electoral anticipado
así lo han denominado organismos
Defensores de derecho civiles como
medios de comunicación internacionales y
locales y Es que hoy cerraron campaña 22
candidatos presidenciales pero habrían
sido 25 de no ser por la exclusión de
tres candidatos por orden del tribunal
supremo electoral al parecer estos tres
candidatos excluidos habrían amenazado
lo que aquí en Guatemala se conoce como
el pacto de corruptos un establecimiento
de personas pertenecientes a familias
poderosas antiguos militares y
funcionarios en las tres ramas del poder
público estos tres excluidos son la
líder indígena de izquierda Telma
Cabrera como los empresarios antisistema
Carlos Pineda y Roberto arzú quienes a
lo sumo debieron haber recibido multas
por las faltas en que incurrieron esto
de acuerdo con human right en lugar de
haber sido expulsados de forma
arbitraria entre tanto son tres
candidatos los más reconocidos y
opcionados para pasar a segunda vuelta
en estos comicios Sandra Torres edmon
mulet y Suri Ríos candidatos
presidenciales cuyos proyectos políticos
oscilan entre la derecha entre el centro
y la extrema derecha con propuestas para
erradicar la corrupción la pobreza y la
inseguridad los resultados preliminares
la tendencia de estos resultados se
conocerá a partir de las 9:30 de la
noche hora local de este domingo 25 de
junio